are you the kind of person who likes to
play xbox 360 games on the Xbox one well
then it's your lucky day because even
more games have been added to the
backwards compatibility program and I'm
going to run you through them I'm Matt
this is a game spot news update and make
sure to LIKE and subscribe so you're the
first person to know when more backwards
compatible games are announced starting
today you'll be able to get your puzzle
on in Luxor to shoot giant balls and mad
balls and babo invasion and play one
weird game of cards in poker smash of
course the granddaddy of all of today's
games is the original Street Fighter 4
it's a bit of a bummer that they didn't
add super street fighter 4 or any of the
other updated versions you know the ones
that people actually still own but if
you've been wanting to play a street
fighter game on xbox one now's your
chance the xbox one backwards
compatibility program started in
November 2015 and since then is
accumulated more than 320 games you can
check them all out on gamespot com but
if you want to watch something about a
new Xbox one game check out the latest
episode of the lobby where we discuss
our early impressions of Mass Effect
Andromeda
[Music]